[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv
60,18 bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
nous sommes le mercredi 21 novembre tout
de suite les titres
il est en représentation au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
jusqu'à demain soir patrick timsit
présente le livre de ma mère mise en
scène par dominique pitoiset adaptation
du roman d'albert cohen paru en 1954 le
comédien joue ce spectacle depuis trois
ans entretient à la fin de ce genre
c'est en ce moment la semaine de
l'éducation attrape un événement animé
également par les jeunes de la ville les
lycéens de la plaine de neuf ans
présenté hier une série de conférences
sur des thèmes littéraires et
scientifiques
un exercice devant professeurs élus et
aussi un inspecteur de l'académie de
versailles
et puis retour sur l'opération job prono
organisait ce mardi au pôle paris ouest
à maurepas plusieurs enseignes ont
rencontré 60 jeunes sélectionnés par la
mission locale focus notamment sur un
restaurant qui proposait 12 postes à
pourvoir invités de cette édition
olivier afonso conseiller municipal
d'opposition à voisins le bretonneux il
a tout récemment annoncé sa candidature
pour les élections municipales de 2020
il reste à la tête la tête de renault
en tout cas pour le moment carlos ghosn
n'a pas été démis de ses fonctions de
pdg du groupe automobile français
implantés notamment dans les yvelines et
décisions prises dans la nuit par le
conseil d'administration et ce malgré
les accusations qui pèsent à l'encontre
du dirigeant carlos ghosn est accusé
pour rappel de fraude fiscale et d'abus
de bien social au japon en tant que
président de l'alliance renault nissan
mitsubishi sa garde à vue a d'ailleurs
été prolongée de dix jours par les
autorités locales
l'intérim cherono sont rassurés par son
numéro deux thierry à bolloré est en
revanche le conseil a d'administration
du groupe nissan dont le siège europe
ouest est implantée à voisins le
bretonneux a déjà demandé le départ de
carlos ghosn
c'était dans le cadre de la semaine de
l'éducation attrape hier le lycée de la
plaine de neauphle organisait une série
de conférences ce sont les lycéens eux
mêmes qui se sont prêtés à l'exercice
ils ont présenté leur projet au public
reportage de marie lehn yapi chinois au
lycée de la plaine de neauphle attrape
ce sont les élèves qui font des
conférences
il est très important pour nous de
donner la parole aux élèves pour déjà
travaillé la prise de parole devant un
public ce qui n'est pas anodin
effectivement et pour parce que se
lassent les entraînera à leurs épreuves
du bac et bas à leur vie après ils ont
participé au jury du prix goncourt des
lycéens menant l'un d'entre eux a
représenté l'ile-de-france à l'elysée
remporter un prix national de sciences
et mener une recherche scientifique avec
des chercheurs de thales ce soir ils
présentent leur expérience à un public
bah on a pris quatre heures un petit peu
plus et on sait mais en groupe par deux
des chats cas a fait son travail
on s'est préparé sur la moitié de
l'année de première s
donc on a présenté notre projet des
scientifiques notre prof avait appelé au
lycée j'ai ensuite ont été sélectionnés
à un concours qui s'appelle de concours
c'est génial et on a été envoyé à
toulouse pour président pour présenter
notre projet une prise de parole face à
leurs professeurs mais aussi un
inspecteur de l'académie et des élus de
la ville de trappes
on a besoin de compter vous qu'on fait
quand même une conférence pour nous en
soi et pour nous scientifique basse et
c'est comme si on était dans la peau
d'un vrai scientifiques ont présenté les
zones de recherche danse du coup là
c'est très cool merci d'être qu'en fait
je crois que je peux le dire enseignants
donc merci porte une image de votre
établissement scolaire mais l'image de
cette ville de trappes des projets
riches avec des résultats qui font la
fierté de l'établissement
la proviseure tenais à ce qu'il puisse
partager cette expérience
en cette semaine de l'éducation au
chapitre politique pas de visite d'
emmanuel macron au salon des maires de
france comme promis il y a un an le
président de la république a choisi de
recevoir une centaine de maires à
l'elysée ce soir invitation dans un
contexte difficile pour les édiles un
maire sur deux ne souhaite pas se
représenter en 2020 selon un dernier
sondage c'est le cas notamment de
véronique côté millard aux
clayes-sous-bois qui témoignait hier
dans le 20 heures de france 2 parmi les
élus reçus à l'elysée certains des
yvelines comme le maire ait l'air de
maurepas grégory à gary astier d'autres
ont refusé l'invitation des manuels
macron philippe benassaya mer et l'air
de bois d'arcy met en avant est la non
reconnaissance de l'état vis-à-vis des
communes il préfère rester aux côtés de
ses administrés mn décision pour
joséphine coleman ce berger à plaisir
interrogé par nicolas landry
j'ai une vraie sensation aujourd'hui que
le rapprochement du président de la
république avec les élus territoire doit
se faire de façon moins protocolaire
nous les maires on a un vrai souci
aujourd'hui on a un souci de savoir si
l'état
aujourd'hui nous considèrent encore
comme étant des personnes qui ont une
vraie responsabilité au sein de nos
collectivités territoriales eh bien on
se retrouve aujourd'hui pris je dirais
dans une espèce de des taux qui fait que
la population attend de plus en plus de
nous de la proximité nous sommes là pour
ça et en même temps de la part de l'état
on se retrouve avec un un regard
pratiquement de suspicion sur la façon
nous avons de gérer alors on entend des
mères qui veulent démissionner on entend
des martyrs nom assez tu n'en peuvent
plus je vous rassure c'est pas mon cas
elles sont programmées en 2020 mais les
élections municipales se prépare déjà
quelques déclarations de candidature on
vous a parlé de celle du maire de
trappes guy malandain qui se présentera
pour un nouveau mandat à voisins le
bretonneux on connaît également le
premier candidat au scrutin des
municipales bonsoir olivia fonso bonsoir
et merci
invitez vous êtes conseiller municipal
d'opposition à un voisin président du
groupe tous rassemblés pour voisins et
vous serez donc candidat à divers droite
pour ces municipales
pourquoi déclarer votre candidature si
tôt on a à plus d'un an et demi de ces
municipales oui ça peut surprendre mais
une élection municipale ça se prépare
et celle ci sera vraiment particulière
parce que on voit bien déjà que je ne
suis pas le premier adjoint de madame
rosetti donc je ne m'en vais pas suite à
un désaccord on est vraiment dans
quelque chose de tout à fait normal
il ya un vrai désaccord politique avec
le maire actuel la situation de la ville
est préoccupante
on a là circle le problème de
circulation qui s'aggrave
malgré les promesses des eti du
contournement sud de deux voisins
l'urbanisme la densification de notre
ville se poursuit il ya une dégradation
du cadre de vie qui est constaté par par
tous
et puis aussi je le dis clairement il ya
une accélération chez alexandre résister
au niveau des projets sans la moindre
concertation comme par exemple le
cimetière des qui va être qui va être
imposé au square des 40 arpents qui n'a
fait l'objet d'une étude discussions
avec les conseils quartier les élus donc
à une accélération et dans le cette
accélération dans cette précipitation il
ya pardonnez moi l'expression du grand
n'importe quoi
donc je prends mes responsabilités je
mesure clairement la responsabilité qui
est la mienne mais aujourd'hui je ne
laisserai pas le cadre de vie se
dégrader dans notre ville j'assume mon
rôle d'opposant et je veux écrire avec
levi sinois une nouvelle page a
l'impression que vous êtes conseil au
conseil municipal depuis 2015 vous êtes
également président du conseil de
quartier centre village de jeu de nos 14
e l'était vous lisiez france ah oui j'ai
une expérience j'ai commencé vraiment je
suis président d'une année c'est la
voisin d'une grande copropriété donc qui
me passionne et j'ai été président de
conseil de quartier donc je connais très
bien
cette fonction et puis je en 2015 je me
suis présenté aux élections car là aussi
j'avais envie de mettre les sujets sur
la table et qu'on arrête avec ses
querelles de personnes qui n'intéressent
absolument pas les décinois dans le
communiqué de presse annonçant votre
candidature vous dites
voisins-le-bretonneux ne prend pas les
décisions qui s'imposent pour maintenir
une qualité de vie qui baissent
inexorablement fin de citation alors
vous faisait clairement vous l'avais dit
la gestion de la ville opéré par la mer
alexandra rosetti il ya des vrais
désaccords on l'a compris sur des sujets
tels que la circulation oui alors je
précise bien je n'ai aucun problème
personnel avec avec le maire avec qui je
m'entends parfaitement mais nous avons
effectivement des désaccords sur la
circulation
elle avait promis le son équipe avait
promis de mettre en place des solutions
dites pertinente je m'aperçois
qu'aujourd'hui non seulement n'y a pas
d'idées mais qu'on vante qu'on va
financer une énième étude sur le sujet
en 2019
bon très bien pendant ce temps là qu'est
ce qu'on fait on a fait part de nos
propositions
madame le maire balaie d'un revers de
main les propositions qui lui sont
faites par l'opposition
parce que c'est l'opposition ça aussi
c'est quelque chose que je changerais si
je suis élu maire et si les levy 6 mois
me font confiance
la gestion de notre ville doit changer
les comportements politiques de changer
pour tout vous dire dans mon programme
j'envisage de nommay
un élu de l'opposition maire-adjoint
pour moi quand on est élu on n'y a pas
de souhait du conseil municipal et
associer les habitants aussi connaissant
parfaitement mais parfaitement et c'est
aussi pour ça que j'ai commencé tôt ma
campagne j'ai l'intention de construire
avec eux et pour eux ce nouveau
programme jeune-là arriverai pas avec
des promesses intenables c'est clair
aujourd'hui c'est très très compliqué de
gérer une ville
je ne veux pas non plus être passéiste
parce que je sais bien aussi que la
ville doit évoluer pour autant je ne
suis pas d'accord sur cette
précipitation
aujourd'hui j'apprends qu'on va rénover
des voix parce que c'est à la mode et on
va rénover une voie par exemple qui n'a
pas lieu d'être
il ouvre sont les priorités je ne
comprends pas je sais pas où on va il ya
une précipitation dans dans des
politiques menées qui vous voulez dire
par thiriez sur un programme pluriannuel
ces sas et total chaque année définir
des objectifs tout à fait alors après on
peut effectivement ne pas réussir c'est
la vie mais en tout cas se fixer comme
objectif effectivement aller par année
et puis on reviendra au conseil
municipal on fera un bilan savez je
viens du monde de l'entreprise
donc les rapports de force et objectifs
les entretiens tout ça je t'adore monadé
je ne sais pas faire un projet sans
intégrer les autres voilà est donc
aujourd'hui c'est ce que je veux changer
dans la ville un dernier mot en 20
secondes il nous reste à faire pour
aller parler de votre liste que vous
voulez une liste dynamique et avec de
l'expérience est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à des alliances notamment
avec un autre conseiller municipal
d'opposition thierry gastou qui est
également ancré à droite
voilà tout à fait thierry gazeuse le
connais très bien et figurez vous qu'on
travaille
j'irai pas main dans la main mais on
travaille sous on échange énormément sur
les problématiques de la ville et il m'a
soutenu quand j'ai proposé le l'armement
de la police municipale je le soutiens
dans son recours contre le projet de la
poste on a vocation à être à se
rassembler et nous avons lui et moi une
responsabilité qui est importante c'est
celle de réussir l'alternance en 2020 on
va suivre tout ça les élections
municipales à voisins et dans toute la
france sont programmés les 23 et 30 mars
2020 merci olivier à fond sans merci de
m'avoir avis
et entre un candidat divers droite à ce
scrutin des municipales à voisins le
bretonneux économie une opération skyway
16-25 ce mardi joe chrono se dérouler
sur le pôle commercial paris-ouest un
job dating pour 60 jeunes sélectionnés
par la mission locale pendant deux
heures ils se sont rendus dans plusieurs
enseignes en recherche d'emploi c'est le
cas notamment dans un restaurant de la
zone avec douze postes à pourvoir les
précisions de nicolas landry ici vous
traversez la rue et vous trouverez
sûrement un emploi 12 postes sont à
pourvoir dans ce restaurant
six personnes en salle et six employés
en cuisine pour former une équipe stable
une situation devenue préoccupante
depuis l'ouverture en juillet dernier on
est obligés de fermer le lundi le
dimanche et certaines fois même limité
certains services faute de personnel
certains services où on est vraiment
très limités on a été jusqu'à
environ cent vingt 120 personnes mais
c'est vrai que l'objectif c'est toujours
d'être au maximum de la capacité
on va dire que le resteront tourne à 50%
de ce que ce qui devrait chef de cuisine
second commis chef de salle ou serveur
actuellement ils sont six salariés en
roulement pour assurer toutes ses
fonctions débutants ou expérimentés
motivé avec la volonté d'apprendre voilà
les profils recherchés
on a des fiches techniques qui
correspond à toutes les montages de tous
les
toutes les préparations ça me permet par
exemple de monter un burger rien qu'en
regardant
le schéma cette enseigne a participé à
jobs chrono une initiative de ski ou et
16,25 pour aider les magasins de paris
ouest a recruté cinq jeunes ont été
reçus dans ce restaurant de personnes
pourraient être embauchés le recrutement
se fait sur les enseignes en deux heures
de temps on our un credo de deux heures
avec des mini cv voilà tout est réduit
mais pour avoir une qualité maximale
dans l'entretien et recrutement sur les
60 candidats ayant participé à jobs
chrono 5 promesse d'embauché ont été
formulées une deuxième édition devrait
avoir lieu sur un autre pôle commercial
de saint quentin en yvelines durant le
premier semestre 2010 9,1 mots de sport
la coupe de france de football avec le
tirage au sort du 8e tour mardi soir et
une affiche de prestige pour le fc
versailles le club accueillera le rc
lens champion de france 1998 est les
sang et or évolue aujourd'hui en ligue 2
soit trois divisions au-dessus des
yvelinois
un match forcément particulier pour le
gardien de but versailles et charles
itandje ex pros qui a joué pour lens
entre 2001 et 2007
rencontre au stade mont boron la date à
définir samedi 8 ou dimanche 9 décembre
prochain à villepreux les habitants ont
été frappés par la fièvre du jeu ce
week-end avec un festival entièrement
dédié à l'amusement rendez vous qui a
attiré plus de 2500 personnes michael et
demi d'euros et nicolas landry une bonne
dose de rire et d'amusement à villepreux
la commune organisé son 4e festival du
jeu au complexe sportif alain mimoun
au programme 18 heures de jeu sur le
week end le festi jeu c'est un
rendez-vous pour toute la famille qui
comprend des jeux de société des jeux
vidéo des jeux jeunesse et qui a pour
vocation de permettre à chacun de passer
un bon moment pendant deux jours dans la
salle on a gagné on a perdu et les
visiteurs ont pu découvrir de nouveaux
jeux moins connus du grand public
alors le jeu consiste à gagner
non sérieusement en fait c'est la soeur
de dominos néo domino intelligent en
plaçant des tuiles ça nous permet de
gagner de ressources et ensuite la façon
d'utiliser les ressources ça ne permet
de gagner des points aux fruits
utilisation ali moi j'ai bien joué on
ferait des civilisations en parallèle
des jeux de société une association
proposait aux visiteurs de se glisser
dans la peau d'un guerrier du moyen-âge
à travers un jeu de rôle ici vous
n'entendrez pas le fracas des épées les
hommes sont en mousse
là les activités qu'on fait ça va le
faire découvrir aux plus jeunes un peu
bas à prendre un peu à se battre avec
des armes qui sont sécurisées et avec
des gestes qu'ils sont
alors lui aussi fait le plus esthétique
possible quoi au total le festival du
jeu a accueilli ce week-end la plus de
2500 personnes des chiffres en constante
augmentation
la partie n'est peut-être pas encore
terminée et jusqu'à jeudi soir patrick
timsit se produit sur la scène du
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines avec le libre de ma mère une
adaptation du livre d'albert cohen où
ils friedrich qui a rencontré le
comédien patrick jacques de dixmude et
michael et demi d'euros pour les moyens
techniques
il sera donc ici sur la scène du théâtre
avec national à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour trois
représentations du livre de ma mère
d'albert cohen 20 21 et 22 novembre
patrick timsit bonsoir et merci de nous
accorder un petit moment avant de monter
sur scène pour cette première
représentation ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est la troisième tournée de spectacles
oui vous avez le même plaisir à monter
sur scène je dirais on ne peut pas dire
encore plus ça voudrait dire que avance
en un témoin donc j'ai dit oui au temps
et puis mais à chaque fois différent
c'est ce qui est formidable il pas
jamais l'impression de me répéter
en plus là on est dans une dans un dans
un moment où je dirais que au lieu de
faire une deux puces en fine de moins
parce qu'on se rapproche d'une fin de
troisième tournée dans des lieux
magnifiques là je viens de voir le
théâtre c'est splendide
je vais avoir l'occasion de jouer aussi
à l'opéra comique en janvier puis aux
célestins à lyon payet il a vraiment une
belle tournée et puis surtout ce
spectacle j'ai vraiment que je me régale
moi c'est un résident dans le fait de
jouer ce spectacle encore et encore est
ce que vous la dalle vaut mieux perdre
parce que je vais le jouer trente ans
oui c'est vrai vous avez eu le temps
avant de passer le pas voilà voilà
trente ans avant de le jouer et là je
redis que contraire la maturité va le
faire progresser dans l'émotion dans la
simplicité dans le rien justement aller
vers le rien le non-jeu l'émotion pure
quoi et donc quelle était la question et
on va y revenir on va déjà parlé du
livre de ma mère c'est un hommage
douloureux d'un fils à sa mère elle
livre sorti en 1954 albert cohen qui
raconte l'amour reçu depuis son enfance
et un livre de deuil
à aucun moment vous ne vouliez tomber
dans le pathos pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas encore compris le
plaisir de venir vous voir jouer sur
scène on va on va peut-être pas en
parler un petit peu en bien sûr et
évidemment c'est un vous j'en parlais
très bien c'est un livre de deuil c'est
un lit ou ou albert cohen nous fait part
de ses souvenirs des moments comme ça du
quotidien et puis après du
questionnement de la perte parce que
c'est sur la mort quand même de la mer
et on voulait ni que ce soit pathos qui
que ce soit de look donc l'adaptation
non je m'amuse pas adaptées au fur et à
mesure de jeu évidemment ça va être sur
les intonations sur les temps sur le
rythme où je ne me répète pas où c'est à
chaque fois différent mais ça reste du
albert cohen en revanche avec le metteur
en scène dominique pitoiset immense
rencontre metteur en scène d'opéra je
voulais absolument que ce soit quelqu'un
que je ne connaissais pas et donc on a
pris le temps de deux 2 voilà de se
tourner autour de sa voix on venait
d'univers différents
en fait on est très proche donc oui
c'est une adaptation du livre où il ya
tous ces moments qui sont légers et il
ya aussi ces moments qui m'ont
rapprocher du livre et qui m'ont fait
vouloir et donner envie d'en faire un
spectacle vont vous y retrouver dans ce
livre cette histoire fait lire une
phrase une phrase vous aviez dit à
l'époque qu'elle vous y retrouviez
vraiment si flotte un peu pour croire
que tout ne va pas si mal que ça et
surtout sourit n'oublie pas de sourire
souris pour escroquer ton désespoir
absolument c'est le premier paragraphe
du livre et quand tout d'un coup vous
passer de un homme chaque homme est seul
et tout se fige de tous et nos douleurs
sont une île déserte cinquième plus tard
et surtout sourit n'oublie pas de
sourire souris pour escroquer ton
désespoir c'est quand même ça ça colle
ça match quoi albert cohen quitte la
grèce avec sa mère il a quatre ans moi
je quitte algérie avec ma mère mes
parents lui aussi avec ses parents
d'ailleurs mais moi j'ai deux ans et
puis on atterrit tous les deux à
marseille finalement quand je dis on
atterrit c'est plutôt qu'on la mairie
puisque on arrive on sort du bateau et
puis voilà moi j'ai été à paris lui
après a continué ses études plus tard à
genève
mais il ya ce côté aussi sur l'immigré
sur sur le regard de l'autre sur les
souvenirs qu'on a les souvenirs de de
cuisiner souvenir de deux des moments
partagés avec une mère qui vous donnent
des codes et on a aussi les mêmes codes
entre l'éducation du maire dit juive dj
parce que je sais pas si je reprendrai
l'expression mais c'est justement pour
dire que l'une merlus ça devient une
intitulée je dirais c'est pas une merde
qui est de confession juive c'est une
mère juive dans ce genre d'éducation ces
mères trop cm représente ces mère
omniprésente ses maîtres au premier
présente parfois aussi et ses codes
qu'elle vous donne fait de moi ton
objets et albert cohen dans une ère qui
n'est pas dans le spectacle la france
que je vais dire mais qu'il a il dit
dans une interview
avec pivot où il reçoit robe de chambre
à genève il était très très absent des
médias puis un jour il a donné cette
interview et il a dit ma mère n'avait
pas d'ego puisque son moi c'était moi
voilà donc vous voyez ça va loin dans
l'éducation
aujourd'hui un film plus que jamais vous
vous y retrouver dans ce spectacle et
surtout est-ce que vous vous sentez
légitime aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya eu
ce long moment où vous n'osiez pas le
jouer là avec plus de 100 120
représentations trois tournées c'est bon
vous sentez légitime vraiment j'ai eu
besoin de prendre confiance c'est pas à
moi de dire que je suis légitime mais là
heureusement les ayants-droit d'albert
cohen donc les érectile ceux qui sont
garantes de de l'oeuvre d'albert cohen
ont vraiment
et me voir régulièrement viennent me
voir régulièrement me pas régulièrement
- cris qui s'était absolument tous
étaient heureux du travail qui avait été
fait plus du spectacle qui est rendu
dominique pitoiset aussi mais mis en
confiance les mettant le metteur en
scène louis mais les producteurs aussi
ou qui a tout mon entourage comme ça qui
est à dire un moment où il gémit 30 ans
et cette maturité professionnelle
peut-être justement pour simplifier pour
être dans l'émotion pure pour ne pas
avoir de démonstration d'acteurs ou de
comédiens à faire peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui je pourrais dire que
j'arrive à ne rien faire vous aviez peur
du regard du public
peut-être commencer habituel mais je
vais vous dire que c'est pas final c'est
pas la plus grande peur c'était pas
passer le drop
je suis comique et jean non le public je
pense pas qu'ils le public peut se
tromper c'est à dire que tout d'un coup
quand il pas se tromper sur le spectacle
se trompent et deux spectacles arrivé en
pensant en rire et va tomber sur ce
spectacle qui ne va qu est n'est pas un
stand up comme on a l'habitude de venir
me voir mais j'ai eu tous les exemples
c'est à dire que des gens qui sont
arrivés où j'avais des amis qu'ils ont
là là j'ai eu peur pour toi je me suis
dit tu vas souffrir ils vont souffrir
des gens qui arrivera journée pourrie on
va bien se marrer et tout d'un coup ils
entendent chaque homme est seul et tout
se fichent de tous et nos douleurs sont
déserts débat ça commence bien et est
finalement il paraît qu'ils étaient en
larmes et debout en train d'applaudir à
la fin du spectacle
donc ça rassurer et puis il ya aussi non
la peur que j'avais ça ne pas rendre
service à une oeuvre que vous aimez
c'est horrible vous êtes quand même
représente ambassadeur de ce livre vous
avez envie de dire aux gens c'est un
livre fantastique fabuleux qui a
bouleversé ma vie
et puis des questions si à se poser ça
va jusqu'à dieu râ les questionnements
adieu les questionnements au sens de la
vie la vie est une farce et puis aussi
ces deux derniers paragraphes
l'avant-dernier paragraphe qui est un
appel aux fils des mers encore vivante
n'oubliez plus que vos mères sont
mortelles je n'aurais pas écrit tout 120
c'est d'un goût ce soit après avoir
écouté mon champ de banc et plus doux
avec sa mère soyez dusan jours avec moi
trouvèrent donc un message comme un
petit passe après on dit tiens et boum
les gens souvent appel leur mère à la
sortie du spectacle quand ils viennent
paraître quand c'est pas leur mère qui
les amène ou qui me les envoie après et
puis il ya le dernier paragraphe qui qui
qui rend le spectacle universel qui est
lourd j'avoue donc c'est un hommage aux
mères mais lourd j'avoue merde tous les
pays maire de toute la terre nos dames
les verts voilà donc ça s'il ya un côté
universel qui me plaît énormément aussi
à jouer et à véhiculer
on vous en parlait avec une telle
passion qu'on a du mal à imaginer vous
puissiez adapter un autre spectacle
remonter sur scène pour un spectacle
d'humour peut-être faire autre chose
tout à l'heure où j'ai su oui mais pas
que répète que ça justement l'homme
repose de l'autre moi je suis donc on a
l'impression que je suis touche à tout
mais en fait tout se rejoint
c'est les mêmes démarches avec des
humeurs différentes je dirais donc oui
des comédies je sais ce que je dis aux
gens je vous dois une comédie donc je
ferai une comédie jauge
aidons pas longtemps d'ailleurs ce qui
m'empêchera pas de revenir au livre
demain de ma mère mais il y aura un jeu
j'espère que j'aurai d'autres bouquins
il ya des livres qui m'ont et qui m'ont
marqué aussi et pourquoi pas mais là
pour l'instant j'aime bien où ça va je
suis encore de ceux qui je fais des
choses différentes mais pas tous en même
temps
merci beaucoup patrick timsit merci
présentons ici au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines jusqu'à jeudi
soir à l'est avant de se quitter notre
petit tour hebdomadaire dans les salles
saint-quentinoise direction ce soir le
ciné 7 à elancourt la programmation du
cinéma est présenté au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude
alors cette semaine au ciné c'est une
avant première exceptionnelle en
partenariat avec lion's club pour lutter
contre l'illettrisme dimanche à 18h15 la
projection du film rémi sans famille
avec daniel auteuil et le tarif est
exceptionnel parce qu'à une partie des
recettes qui sera versée à la lutte
contre l'illettrisme via le lion's-club
voilà et la semaine prochaine le nouveau
la nouvelle le nouvel opus du festival
saint quentin festival du film
documentaire dont il ya plein de choses
qui vont se dérouler du 28 novembre au 2
décembre notamment deux soirées
exceptionnelles lui le 29 à l'ugc la
soirée d'ouverture en présence des
frères bogdanoff et la soirée de clôture
qui se déroulera le 2 décembre à partir
de 16 heures au ciné cette avec la
projection de 16 levers de soleil qui
sera suivie de la remise du prix tv
60,18 du privé cinéma et des prix du
public parce que le public peut voter
pour son film préféré par les sept
documentaires en compétition et tout
cela sera suivi d'un cocktail le plus
chaleureux possible nous le souhaitons
bien sûr pour toutes ces informations
vous pouvez
vous inscrire aussi pour ses soirées sur
le site ww point 50-1 point fr c'est la
fin du set 8 journal dans un instant le
7-8 débat que reste-t-il du combat
contre les violences faites aux femmes
c'est la question posée par manon
varaldo à ses invités belle soirée avec
tv 78
[Musique]